und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend bei der FDP erinnern Sie
sich noch an den Shitstorm den einst
Parteichef Lindner erntete als er der
Fridays for future Bewegung mitteilte
Zitat Klimapolitik sei was für Profis
das kam nicht so gut an junge Menschen
möchten zumindest ernst genommen werden
auch von den Liberalen zumal die FDP ja
selbst gerne auf die Verantwortung
gegenüber nachfolgenden Generationen
verweist um ihr Festhalten an der
Schuldenbremse zu begründen das ernst
nehmen demonstrierte heute nun FDP
Verkehrsminister Wissing als er sich mit
Vertretern der letzten Generation traf
Christian hübsche hat das beobachtet
diesmal sind sie offiziell eingeladen
kommen schick im Anzug noch vor acht
Wochen beschmierte die selbsternannte
letzte Generation auch wissingshausen
mit Farbe dann schreiben sie ihm Herr
Wissing wir möchten reden er habe
keinerlei Verständnis für Straftaten
sagte Verkehrsminister aber er lädt sie
ins Ministerium mich überzeugen die
Argumente der letzten Generation nicht
und deswegen bin ich dialogbereit und
darüber zu sprechen warum man wenig
fordert und
viel Blockade betreibt aus der
vereinbarten Stunde werden über zwei
Stunden ein menschlich sehr gutes
Gespräch nennt es danach die
Mitgründerin der selbst ernannten
letzten Generation
über die wir reden wollten allen voran
dass eine antriebswende natürlich nicht
reicht dass wir eine echte Verkehrswende
brauchen der Minister lässt danach nur
seinen Sprecher schriftlich mitteilen
das Gespräch war ein sachlicher
Austausch von Positionen und Argumenten
kein Grund für die klimaaktivisten ihren
Berliner Straßenkampf zu beenden sie
fordern ein Tempolimit und einen neuen
Euro statt 49 Euro Ticket für Aktionen
wie diese wurden allein heute mehr als
50 Menschen in Gewahrsam genommen
der Protest den werden wir ja
weitermachen dass es klar der ist
notwendig der hat uns ja auch in dieses
Gespräch überhaupt geführt immerhin man
will sich bald ein zweites Mal mit
Wissing treffen und hofft nun auch auf
ein Gespräch mit Bundeskanzler Scholz
fast jede politische Partei hat oder
hatte das was man im Netz als Troll
bezeichnet wobei das genderneutral zu
verstehen ist es gibt sie männlich wie
weiblich Personen die regelmäßig
provozieren Profile und Popularität
gerade dadurch stärken dass sie sich
gegen die eigene Partei Linie
positionieren oder zumindest Sprüche
raushauen die den meisten anderen
Mitgliedern die Zornes oder Schames
rütte ins Gesicht treiben ihm oder ihr
aber ein erster Reihe Platz in den
Medien sichern bei den Grünen heißt bzw
hieß der Troll Boris Palma wie die
Partei jetzt auf seinen Austritt
reagiert berichtet Eva Schiller
Boris Palmer ein Meister der Provokation
der jetzt stürzt über ihre Provokation
erst ein Bruder Holocaust Vergleich in
der späteren Rede an der Uni Frankfurt
spricht Palma dann noch mehrfach das
diskriminierende N-Wort aus
durch auch hier in diesem Raum es folgt
ein Sturm der Entrüstung wie so oft nach
Palmas Provokationen doch diesmal anders
sein schriftliches Schuldeingeständnis
als Politiker und Oberbürgermeister
hätte ich niemals zu reden dürfen
Palma tritt endgültig bei den Grünen aus
hätte er es nicht getan Vera wohl
geflogen aufatmen bei vielen in der
Partei nach diesen Äußerungen jetzt den
selbst die Reißleine zieht es
respektabel und ich wünsche ein gutes
Leben aber da ist auch ein fanflügel
einst hätte baden-Württembergs
Ministerpräsident Palma gern als
Nachfolger gesehen das ist vorbei aber
ich habe gesagt dass es mir persönlich
leid tut dass wir diesen klugen Kopf der
unsere Partei
über eine sehr lange Zeit streitbar
bereichert hat dass wir den jetzt nicht
mehr in der Partei haben
Tübingens Bürgermeister bleibt Palma hat
sich aber einen Monat Auszeit verordnet
sein jetzt Zorn hier offenes Geheimnis
gut finden ihn trotzdem viele er hat
vielleicht viele Wähler enttäuscht auch
durch seine Äußerung aber ich denke er
sollte schon im Amt bleiben ich hoffe
dass er sich jetzt Zeit für sich selbst
und hilft ihm bei Herzen aber wer Boris
Palma kennt kann sich schwer vorstellen
das ist nach seiner Nachdenkpause
wirklich ruhig um ihn wird
wer sich an die Anfänge des Internets
erinnert erinnert sich auch daran dass
es den Begriff Google noch gar nicht gab
diese Marktdominanz hat der Konzern erst
im Laufe der Zeit erworben neben anderen
tech-riesen wie Microsoft Apple oder
Amazon sie sind so mächtig geworden dass
man sie Gatekeeper nennt Unternehmen die
wie Türsteher mit breiten Schultern
darauf achten dass kein anderer mehr
reinkommt auf den Markt den sie
beherrschen die Europäische Union geht
nun mit einem Gesetz dagegen vor der
Wettbewerb soll fairer werden und
kleineren Unternehmen den Zutritt
erleichtern Isabel Schäfers berichtet
es ist ein ungleicher Kampf den sie bei
next Cloud führen das deutsche
Unternehmen bietet Anwendungen für die
digitale Arbeitswelt an Mail Cloud Chat
die Produkte sind Open Source also
gratis für Privatkunden dennoch greifen
die meisten Nutzer auf die
Konkurrenzprodukte des Tech Giganten
Microsoft zurück
für uns ist dadurch dass next glaube
nicht vorinstalliert ist sondern die
entsprechenden Produkte von Microsoft
und Google vorinstalliert sind bei
Windows oder Android beispielsweise dann
ist es einfach sehr schwierig für uns
als kleines Unternehmen das nicht der
Fuß zu fassen die will gegensteuern mit
dem Digital marketsact kleineren
Anbietern soll ein fairer Wettbewerb
ermöglicht die Marktmacht der großen
tech-konzerne begrenzt werden Apple darf
zum Beispiel in seinem App Store künftig
nicht mehr den eigenen Bezahldienst
bevorzugen Amazon seine
selbstvertriebenen Produkte nicht mehr
besser stellen und Microsoft seine
verschiedenen Dienste nicht mehr als
Paket vorinstallieren die EU-Kommission
überwacht die Einhaltung der Regeln
verstöße werden sanktioniert mit bis zu
20% des weltweiten Umsatzes
die großen Tech-Unternehmen haben ihre
Praktiken nicht schnell genug selbst
verändert deshalb brauchen wir jetzt ein
Gesetz um zu sagen so sollt ihr euch
verhalten wenn ihr so mächtig seid mit
Macht kommt auch Verantwortung
die neuen Regeln gelten nur für die Tech
Giganten die den Markt dominieren
sogenannte torwächterunternehmen
ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass
Torwächter Unternehmen natürlich auch in
Zukunft mit neuen Ideen um die Ecke
kommen wie man die Konkurrenz klein
halten kann und dass die Kommission dann
entsprechend nachbessern muss ob die
alternativen Produkte der kleinen
Anbieter künftig tatsächlich mehr
genutzt werden hängt aber auch von den
Nutzern ab
und jetzt die Nachrichten
Vertreter aus rund 40 Staaten beraten
heute und morgen in Berlin beim
Petersberger klimadialog zur
Vorbereitung des Weltklimagipfels Ende
November in Dubai
Außenministerin baerbock war für eine
Einigung auf einen globales Ziel für
erneuerbare Energien mit einem massiven
Ausbau insbesondere auch in Afrika könne
man gemeinsam dafür sorgen doch auf den
1,5°c
trifft mit seinen Überlegungen zu einem
niedrigeren industriestrompreis auf
Skepsis Finanzminister Lindner schrieb
in einem Gastbeitrag für das
Handelsblatt die Verbesserung der
internationalen Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
steht ganz oben auf seine Agenda in
erster Linie auf direkte staatliche
Hilfe zu setzen sei allerdings
ökonomisch und klug
der deutsche Chip-Hersteller infineon
hat in Dresden offiziell den Bau einer
weiteren Fabrik begonnen und eine
Milliarde Euro öffentlicher Fördermittel
sollen in das Projekt investiert werden
beim symbolischen Spatenstich am
Nachmittag sagt die Bundeskanzler Scholz
Halbleiter sein dass Erdöl des 21
jahrhunderts ab 2026 sollen sie in der
neuen Fabrik gefertigt werden damit will
sich Europa von Asien unabhängiger
machen
wegen der Kämpfe im Sudan sind nach
UN-Angaben in dem Land mehr als 330.000
Menschen auf der Flucht in den
Nachbarländern vor allem Ägypten aber
auch im Chat suchten seit Mitte April
mehr als 100.000 Menschen Zuflucht das
Land grenzt an die westsudanesische
Unruhe Region darf vor wo zuletzt die
Gewalt wieder zugenommen hat auch in der
Hauptstadt wird weiter gekämpft am
Donnerstag soll eine siebentägige
Waffenruhe beginnen
noch eine Meldung vom Tennis beim ATP
Masters in Madrid hat Daniel Altmaier
das Viertelfinale erreicht Alexanders
verif dagegen hat das nicht geschafft
ihr unterlag knapp einen Monat vor
Beginn der French Open im Achtelfinale
von Madrid klar dem Spanier Carlos
die Wetteraussichten für Morgen meist
scheint die Sonne im Norden und Südosten
kann es aber auch mal mehr Wolken und
vereinzelt Schauer geben die Temperatur
steigt der vierte von 12 bis 22 Grad die
weiteren Aussichten auch am Donnerstag
überwiegt der Sonnenschein und es kann
bis 25 Grad warm werden ab Freitag wird
es wieder unbeständiger
das war es auch schon von uns bis morgen
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]